congés movie une chose à reyers c'est
fort non c'est pas ça réussit à passer
partout
alors si lo gagne toujours pourquoi
est-ce qu'on persiste à essayer de la
contenir avec du sable
c'est la question que se posent alain
gingras les fameuses digues de sacs de
sable ne comprends pas comment elles
marchent pas fait c'est celle hâtivement
à 5
on utilise des pages à sabres qui vont
enfin comme un mur de la direction veut
dire relativement simple pour lui jean
françois bégin qui a pas mal du 34e
régiment de génie de combat qu'on
appelle les pages à 100 mais quand les
contacts toutes les pages à saab ont
refusé la forme l'homme de l'eau dans la
majorité des cas c'est sa classe sont
perméables c'est souhaitable que ce soit
perméable pour que l'eau solidifie le
tout selon françois brice est professeur
au département de génie la construction
de l'école de technologie supérieure
c'est très important qu'on puisse créer
bien les compacts et pour que la
jonction entre l'ailé les sags devienne
le moins possible jouer de faiblesse si
on met une seule rangée de sacs ça peut
contenir environ 30 à 40 cm d'eau
maximum mieux vaut construire en
pyramide beaucoup plus efficace ça va
faire cependant c'est trop quatre fois
moins d'eau donc ce n'est jamais
complètement interne et abl le but c'est
pas trés murmuré temps c'est impossible
de faire ce avec des murs de sa peu
importe la technique aubry qu on peut
voir qu'il est de défendre de craquer ce
que l'eau peuvent s'infiltrer dans ce
qui si ce ne sont faces laisser partir
mais dont la voix si la technique du
caporal des gens entre l'eau et les
pages rassemble on ajoute une couche de
plastique polythène une différence d'au
moins 50 centimètres devant et derrière
la digue le reste il faut le pomper ou
le soufflé bref comment être efficace
avec les moyens du bord